er hat keine 044 leute es ist ganz schön
lange her
fühlt sich an als wäre es jahre her dass
ich das letzte mal minecraft gespielt
habe und eine minecraft video auf
youtube channels gemacht habe aber heute
habe ich bock minecraft zu zocken
deswegen zocken wir minecraft und wir
machen wieder eine challenge und zwar
die twitter challenge und zwar habe ich
euch auf twitter gebeten mir wörter zu
geben die man lieber nicht auf twitter
posten sollte wir sind auf bergwerk labs
zocken
wir werden es heute so machen für jeden
zweiten jump ja nicht für jeden sondern
für jeden zweiten job will werde ich mir
eins der wörter von eurer leckel ist der
verbotenen toter weiter aussuchen und
das iphone so post nach twitter ohne
irgendwas außen rum zu erzählen ich habe
niemanden darauf vorbereitet das ist
jetzt kommt und wir schauen mal was ihr
so steht hus besuch an der porta raus
wird die raushauen welt die einfach mal
so stehen lassen da er und dann wissen
auch versuche die reaktion mit
einzufangen und junge ich habe richtig
schiss runterzufallen okay das ding auch
bisschen tricky muss man glaube ich hier
und dann so la la la la la la das war
schon wieder ein bisschen klos okay ich
schaue jetzt alles doppelt und dreifach
und ganz genau an weil ich eigentlich
ganz gerne auch nicht von twitter
gebannt werden würde muss ich euch auch
ganz deutlich zu sagen da habe ich
eigentlich nicht so lust auf das denkbar
so kommen was ist hier für die erste
module sind ja eigentlich sieht
normalerweise rasche hierdurch ein
gestörter und weiß natürlich auf fels
aber heute heute nicht heute heute
gucken war dass es ihr wissen an die
million dollar hat das gemerkt das war
schon richtig klaus erwarte ich keine
punkte gar nicht so verkorkst eigentlich
modul 3 profi
davon ist das gap face the way erp face
wenn wir jetzt so dp vor uns sehen kann
ich ja eigentlich auch schon mal eine
kleine info drop wollte es länger das
video zu machen zu dieser info auch wenn
das manche vielleicht machen und dass
ich auch auf das kann er machen wer will
aber ich werde den war o4 dabei seien
leute
und der dude hat mich eingeladen haben
die letzten zahlen geschrieben
ich war zu dem zeitpunkt ist mega witzig
bei einer party von der uni aus war und
war zu diesem zeitpunkt nüchtern und
hatte dementsprechend auch gar kein
grund einfach mal mich auf eine bank zu
setzen um klar zu kommen besteht ja
natürlich sehr verständlich karten dafür
trotzdem saß ich dann doch irgendwie auf
der bank und habe in diesem moment
nachts um 2 auf twitter gelesen dass bio
ware fir bist du dabei bist du dafür zu
haben
nein nicht erfasst wird natürlich sofort
zugesagt
und ja die info können jetzt am rande
drop okay jetzt vorsichtig das war der
erste feld was okay halt alles klar die
ware group will mit auch gerade schon
auf meinen berlin hätte ich nicht mal
leise machen können übernehme jetzt
jetzt erlebt er live mit was ihr
passiert ok zack bumm
so heiße die schnauze down ganz so weit
geschafft unit sechs füchse
das sieht nicht so gut aus hier
das sieht nicht so gut aus ich glaube
wir kommen nicht um muss im freitod
wählen und damit muss wird auch das
erste mal aus der liste aussuchen des
posten
was haben denn hier pizza penis sex
porno
wie wär's denn mit ok wir wie wir wollen
ja nicht dass die teilchen leben wird ja
deswegen droppen wir direkt direkt mal
am anfang ganz trocken ein
jetzt einfach mal ja ich weiß nicht ich
will euch gar nicht sagen was gepostet
habe das gibt's doch nicht
alter schwede die ersten reaktion
pkp eine menge retweets und höhere penis
gesagt jetzt muss der nächste
schiffsneubau
okay das nächste wort kommt von neid
heldin
sie sagte die ok ok alles klar
da die der die gepostet gott sei dank
findet sie auch gleich zu sagen sie mal
die ersten vor
wer weiß natürlich bisschen ein bisschen
zeit genug auf dem weg dahin ganz klar
aber das kümmert finnischen und wir sind
jetzt wieder bei null game face auf dem
scoreboard bei 2 gibt es wieder den
nächsten frost ich kann man das hier so
bringen
ganz ehrlich ich hab jetzt schon bei 96
gar kein ticket wie alles da diese
momente man einfach so ein video
aufnehmen und sich mit dem video denkt
so habe ich habe ich vielleicht habe ich
vielleicht die falschen entscheidungen
allein getroffen ich skate oder es geld
sorgt sollte man ehrlich posten glaubten
die ganze sache ein bisschen abzukühlen
posten jetzt einfach mal post auf meinen
eigenen namen auf twitter und die ersten
leute schreiben sie haben kopfkino weil
ich der die gepostet hat leute ich werde
richtig richtig und sicher dabei okay
wir haben 1000 54.000 ist sollte
ungefähr nicht okay leute ich sag mal so
wir hatten jetzt nicht die allergrößte
auswahl wir haben chain helmut ansonsten
eisen platz und eine menge wut ich muss
jetzt einfach hard rocker sogar gott das
wird schon gar nicht gut wir haben
nämlich ein sharp 1 stein sperrt
workfare klickt der sache ist pvp auch
immer dass das einfach so krass zum
abstauben bestimmt ist also es irgendwie
so 99 nicht einfach abstimmen wie viel
frisst dennoch geht doch gar nicht
gekämpft alles kannten ja altersklassen
ist haben wir nie eine chance wenn ich
wirklich dir natürlich alle 1000 mal
besseres equipment als wir
okay das geschäft aktiv wir haben jetzt
noch exakt ein leben so was können wir
damit machen das zwischenstück ii
wolle man den kuchen ich kann halt 0
sagen ob wir gegen eine chance haben
wird sagen wir essen wieder voll auf
steht das schild an eine lok okay ist ja
wohl sehr schön das war wichtig ist so
massiv erschwert hat eisen schärfe 1
immerhin schon mal ein schadens punkt
mehr als wir bisher und auch noch eine
alles klar da kommt ihm team hingegen
team körper kopf team natürlich steht
auf dem bogen aufatmen kehren jetzt hier
zeitgleich draufgehen
ja ja ja ja wohl ich habe mich da bin
ich habe ich den arm mitgenommen
jetzt haben nur noch einen gegner wo ist
da nicht das land jetzt xlab von
irgendwo okay da drüben ist ja vom
schiff oben
damit ja wohl der gpk habe man die
kommentare was ihr von meiner seite